quoi s'en passer alors on va parler
évidemment de ces électrohypersensibles
et puis on se demandera s'il ya un vrai
danger dans l'est dans les zones que
nous utilisons on va parler de ce
dossier avec le réalisateur du film mark
cane et puis on va en débattre ensuite
parce que les arguments s'affrontent
avec le neurologue jean pierre marc
vergne des directeur de recherche à
l'inserm de toulouse précise que vous
êtes expert auprès de l'agencé nationale
de sécurité sanitaire anses s la député
europe ecologie les verts laurence
abeilles hauteur de la future loi très
probablement sur la protection face aux
ondes électromagnétiques qui devraient
être votées à la fin du mois de janvier
à côté d'elle etienne cendrier
l'association robin des toits
j'ai bien dit des poissons et milite
contre l'installation en tout cas pour
la prudence dans l'installation des
relais de téléphonie mobile
et puis et erwan seznec de que choisir
qui signé en décembre dernier une
enquête décapante sur le sujet mark cane
d'abord je disais tout à l'heure ça
interpelle mais ces intrigues aussi pour
être très honnête
quant au début de votre film on a le
sentiment d'être parachuté au milieu
d'adeptes d'une secte un peu étrange qui
se réunit au milieu des forêts qui dit
ne plus supporter le téléphone c'est un
parti-pris veut pas non c'est un peu le
parcours que j'ai moi-même vécu c'est à
dire que c'était un sujet mais je
travaille je fais des films sur
l'environnement mais je te connaissais
absolument pas le sujet il doit dire
même j'en avais entendu parler sans
jamais que ça n'imprimons moi comme un
sujet à traiter nos rivaux d'epagny vous
avez un téléphone portable au jardin le
belge avait dû vous l'aviez vous avez
j'avais du wifi j'avais un des sociétés
c'est à dire le téléphone sur socle
enfin voilà j'utilisais ces technologies
chez moi avec des enfants et j'avais
même eu des parents de l'école de mon
village qui s'étaient émus de la
proximité très proche d'une antenne
relais sur le sur l'école les femmes
pouvons aimer comment ai je n'avais pas
pensé à l'époque les rejoindre c'est
parce que j'ai une amie avec lequel j'ai
travaillé donc je la connaissais de
pendant quatre cinq ans on avait fait
des choses ensemble qui tout d'un coup
plus de nouvelles d'elle et quand j'ai
eu des nouvelles c'était pour me dire
enfin pour me faire dire qu elle étai
électrohypersensibles il son mari étant
médecin que j'ai commencé à m'intéresser
à ça alors je suis allée la voir
d'ailleurs en premier lieu pour
simplement par voilà même pas en perdit
pas fort non une relation d'amitié par
amitié tout simplement nous puis elle a
commencé à me parler de ces problèmes et
mais c'est quoi ces problèmes et puis là
j'ai commencé à regarder sur internet
j'ai lu qu'elle n'était pas la seule
j'ai vu une incompréhension quel arrêt
aussi dans sa famille mais j'ai vu que
cette incompréhension était se retrouver
dans tous les témoignages que je voyais
sur internet toujours j'ai fait un appel
moi-même à témoignages que j'ai lancé un
peu comme ça mais comme on lance pour
voir ce qu'il allait advenir au bout
d'une semaine j'avais une trentaine de
mails de traits d'un très précis de
témoignages très long très précis des
personnes qui m'envoyait leurs
souffrances que j'ai après appelé au
téléphone et sa durée 6 mois où j'ai
vues si vous voulez à la fois c'était
moyen âge là j'ai vu les enquêtes
scientifiques ont convoyait celles qui
pensent et quelqu'un qui dise qu'un
problème de santé et puis également
toutes celles qui disent qu'il n'ya
aucun souci j'ai vu également encore une
fois c'est pas une maladie ouais j'ai vu
sur les forums tous les arguments qui
sont développés en disant mais non c'est
une vue d'esprit enfin le monde donc je
ne savais même pas trop combien de temps
d'en quête au bout du coup six mois
comme ça et puis il ya eu ce
rassemblement des électrosensibles dans
la forêt dessous qui commence le film
d'ailleurs la première séquence et là je
me suis pas la seule façon finalement
n'avoir que le coeur net
c'est de vivre avec eux pendant une
semaine c'est ce que j'ai fait alors je
dois dire que j'avais mon le producteur
du film qui était très réticente duzan
me coûte ce septet une phobie enfin
voilà tout le monde ne renvoyez ça et
puis je lui dis ben écoutons ce vient
voir avec moi et on va se faire une idée
ensemble au bout d'une semaine
je veux dire devant les récits la
cohérence de tout ce qui de tout ce que
nous vivions avec eux c'est pas
seulement les récits s'est tout d'un
coup c'est une foule de petits détails
qui est un leader quand on raconte la
même histoire
c'est ça sans avoir rio rist opposition
au téléphone oui c'est pas une secte
d'écolo non non ça c'est vu des gens qui
venaient de la ville un oui mais c'est
cool mon fils mais je dis on avait un
prof d'informatique en avait des gens
qui travaillent dans la téléphonie
mobile on avait des anciens 10 bm on
avait des agriculteurs on avait vraiment
des profils très différents ça déjà ça
nous a marqués et puis tous avec des
relents j'arrête parce que cette image
aller frappante quand vous croisez des
gens comme ça en ville ce sont
généralement des électrosensibles terre
des gens qui se recherche d'un bon signe
mais vous voyez la femme là qu'est en
train de quêter derrière nous la fille
qui se tord de douleur elle venait par
exemple témoigner à montpellier sur sur
ce sujet là c'est cette fille dont elle
venait apporter son témoignage
c'est une fille qui n'est devenu électro
hypersensibles elle était à la faculté
de toulouse
elle faisait des études et puis il ya
une antenne relais qui était bâtie en
face de sa chambre et en un an elle n'a
pas pu suivre la deuxième année parce
que la deuxième année elle a eu tous les
symptômes qui arrivait sans jamais
quelle remarque cette antenne est comme
et à un moment elle a remarqué cette
antenne mais pourquoi je n'arrive plus à
apprendre pourquoi j'aimerais à tête
pourquoi j'ai une ati guéant valent
elles ne pouvaient plus suivre ses
études
hélas elle venait pour témoigner il y
avait du wifi dans cette faculté elle
n'a pas pu rentrer moi je les ai suivis
avec ma caméra parce qu'au départ
j'étais bon voilà quelqu'un qu'elle
caméras sont équipées info le savoir
notamment pour la prise de son de deux
systèmes de wi fi non mais moi je n'ai
pas imaginé bien je vous en avais pas
que vous avez un peu basculer comme non
non non non
vous avez un parti pris très 2011 je
n'avais pas enfin une caméra émet des
ondes dit nous la passion oui mais
disons que j'ai suivi cette fille
j'avais vu je vais vu rentrer dans cette
salle ne plus avoir rentré puis sortir
et se tord de douleur parce qu'elle
était rendrait dans ce lieu où il y
avait du wifi donc vous devez au moment
où elle est sortie une centaine
d'étudiants qui sortait avec leur
portable qui rallie mais tous vous
dites-vous 1 il chic pas y aller raconte
pas d'histoires enfin oui oui absolument
et 2 vous avez vous la certitude que
c'est lié aux ondes des téléphones
portables du wi fi des téléphones sans
fil qu'on a la maison était tous dans
les rets sunnites ou dans les récits
essais le film est construit comme ça
oui c'est logique c'est une
démonstration est tous dans le récit
laisse penser pour moi la preuve
scientifique s'était d'abord je me suis
dit mais pourquoi pas mais pourquoi ne
pas les croire avant d avoir écouté ce
un peu et bien c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on avait effectivement c'est ce qu'on
va continuer à faire d'ailleurs parce
qu'on va les réécouter ça bourdonne ça
bourdonne avec un appareil vous l'avez
peut-être vu dans le film tout à l'heure
à la main c'est le visage de bernard
quand ils traversent un village où tout
d'un coup il ya un émetteur et puis on
l'entend aussi dans la bouche de marine
qui ne supporte même plus que la caméra
vaudry lamerat mais s'approche de
l'écouter c'est le château d'eau du
village qui est plus haut
et là on se rend compte qu'un château
d'eau qui a deux kilomètres et demi
trois kilomètres belle ici et rayonne de
trous pour que je puisse rester les
villages tels que ce village là quand je
le traverse
valve a sorti je me sens mais plus
fatigue et douleurs intenses comme une
brûlure au laser très précisément dans
une partie du cerveau
la plupart du temps la partie frontale
ou du côté où se trouve la source des
émissions la douleur serait de 8 sur 10
sur une échelle rupture de
l'enchaînement normal dépensé perte de
la mémoire de fixation par exemple si je
gare ma voiture je sais pu la retrouver
brûlures qui démangent visible au niveau
du décolleté 4 sur 10 confusion
impossibilité de me concentrer
difficulté à exprimer clairement perte
de certains mots que jean pierre marc
vergne vous avez été longtemps
neurologue est aujourd'hui le directeur
de recherche à l'inserm je le disais
après avoir vu ce film vous dit toujours
il n'ya pas de lien avéré c'est ça la
position scientifique officiel
c'est la position scientifique
officieuse et la position de la n 16 qui
est l'agencé auprès de laquelle vous
êtes expert oui actuellement pas tout à
fait quand même enfin là je je ne peux
malheureusement pas m'exprimer
clairement parce que nous préparons un
rapport sur le sujet qui va sortir
je pense à la fin du printemps si nous
n'arrivons pas à tenir les délais nous
le sortirons début septembre
donc nous sommes en train de voir très
attentivement toute la littérature
nous avons auditionné enfin nous sommes
en cours d'audition des associations de
médecins qui reçoivent ces patients dans
leurs services
et bien sûr nous faisons la revue de la
littérature donc nous avons une synthèse
a fait rentrer tout cela vous êtes en
train de bouger sur vos positions c'est
ça vous êtes en train de me bouger
position officielle de l'aisne c'est ça
je reviens en l'état actuel des
connaissances
aucune preuve scientifique d'une
relation de causalité entre l'exposition
accrochez-vous un peu entre l'exposition
aux radiofréquences et
l'hypersensibilité électromagnétique n'a
pu être apportée autrement dit ils sont
peut-être malade mais pas de ça
ça c'était la conclusion du rapport de
2009 sur les paires sensibilité
électromagnétiques
depuis il ya eu une soixantaine de deux
publications
l'ansès a actuellement une attitude
d'ouverture ça que j'avais sur cette
question ou comment expliquer
aujourd'hui pour ceux qui disent ça
n'est pas lié
comment explique-t-il par exemple les
maux de tête les symptômes que décrivait
marine il y actuellement plusieurs gigas
et aux neurologues que je parle il y
actuellement plusieurs hypothèses qui
ont été avancées même dans le film
certains moments on voit le professeur
le ruz le professeur belpomme c'est ok
vous que certaines hypothèses
pour l'instant à notre connaissance
alors jupe je dois dire que j'ai appris
j'ai appris dans ce film que monsieur le
russe avait fait un rapport sur les
radars il ya déjà avant par les grèves
alors quelques années et que je ne
connaissais pas je ne connaissais pas
pourtant j'ai rencontré plusieurs fois
le professeur le ruz
on n'avait jamais abordé cette question
comment explique-t-on alors un mot tête
par exemple autrement dit est-ce que ce
sont des migraineux qui se sont trouvés
une cause et leur migraine la migraine
est maintenant reconnu comme une maladie
ouais et pourtant elles ne présentent
pas chez les migraineux
il n'y a aucun symptôme objectif ce
qu'on appelle symptômes objectifs des
anomalies à l'examen clinique à l'examen
biologique en radiologie et pourtant on
a réussi à caractériser un tableau
clinique pour l'instant ce qui nous
manque beaucoup actuellement pour
avancer dans cette question
7 j'allais dire un questionnaire qu'ils
puissent se distinguer ces personnes si
c'est possible dès par exemple des
personnes qui sont sensibles aux odeurs
chimiques on en a parlé dans le fayyoum
pour les odeurs chimiques nous avons
actuellement des phtalates les choses
comme ça allait les gens qui se
plaignent d'une sensibilité aux odeurs
chimiques
il leur donne des maux de tête et leur
donne des symptômes qui ressemblent
il n'y a jamais eu une étude comparative
comme vous comme vous êtes prudent quand
même hein on avance on avance doucement
un bon c'était la séance de cela si vous
les faux pas il faut être posée à la
voie de la science avance pas à pas il
faut être enthousiaste et impatient et
le plus rationnelle possible
c'est ce que j'entends c'est là qu'est
ce que c'est toujours difficile à
concilier le politique lui répond à quoi
à une précaution parce que le principe
de précaution dans la constitution c'est
que vous avez déposé une proposition de
loi qui devrait être adoptée fin janvier
je le disais qui va prôner installer un
certain nombre de restrictions de
contrôle vous estimez vous qu'il ya un
danger les ondes des antennes-relais
départ à titre personnel moi j'en suis
convaincu depuis de nombreuses années
c'est vrai ayant vu ce type de
documentaire ayant rencontré des
personnes souffrant
d'électro-hypersensibilité ça a été
renforcée dans mon travail parlementaire
en parlant d'ailleurs avec les
parlementaires de sujets là parce que
eux-mêmes en fait sont sensibilisés à
cette question là par le biais d'amis de
connaissances et donc j'ai même été
moins d'une surprise un devoir que ce
sujet qu on voulait vraiment écarté en
fait ils touchent beaucoup d'élus locaux
dans leur vie quotidienne
alors mais ma démarche elle a été de
dire bon on n'arrive pas actuellement à
avoir ce qu'on appelle des certitudes
sur le plan scientifique c'est très
compliqué même si moi je suis là quand
je le dis je suis absolument convaincu
qu'il ya une dangerosité cette
dangerosité s'accroît constamment
puisque constamment l'électrosmog comme
on l'appelle ou la fa la densité de des
ondes auquel on est exposé avec tous les
nouveaux objets les antennes les
téléphones les tablettes les trois bref
tous ces objets qui nous entourent qui
son émetteur d'ondés électromagnétiques
en fait accroissent la pollution de
notre environnement et moi je veux pas
être sentis environnementale en fait
aussi à travers ce texte là oui mais
vous parlez de santé environnementale
vous me dites pollution même temps vous
me dites moi j'ai pas de preuve que
c'est un oui mais c'est comme ça n'est
une pollution que si c'est dangereux
mais est ce que le législateur n'est pas
un parti pris acte jeudi un point de vue
non non non c'est moi je pense au gré de
l'autre côté on sait très bien que les
ondes électromagnétiques ont un impact
sur l'environnement ça c'est ça c'est
absolument un contexte
oui oui bien sûr puis ce mot et je crois
qu'il faut distinguer ce qui peut être
un effet purement biologique
c'est à dire entièrement réversible et
sans séquelles d'un effet sanitaire
c'est à dire le déclenchement d'une
pathologie ya par exemple d'une rumeur
rumeur par exemple mais mais il peut y
avoir
sans tomber dans la gravité de la tumeur
il peut y avoir d'autres pathologies
moins grave mais néanmoins sérieuse et à
prendre en compte
à condition connaît j'allais dire des
bases sur le sec sur lesquels s'appuyait
pour le diagnostic et pour le traitement
que j'ai un perplexe là bas au fond
c'est ones n'ai jamais voulu
ils vous regardent les jours
inquiétez pas pu rentrer dans le détail
de votre nom mais c'est bien le bassin
des pathologies créé par le rayonnement
est traumatique c'est un coup de soleil
le soleil ce sont des ondes
électromagnétiques
aux etats unis un concours qui existe
depuis de nombreuses années qui
s'appelle own millions de dollars
paranormal conteste la première personne
qui arrivera à détecter des ondes de
téléphones portables wifi sans les voir
à l'aveuglé 15 à 20 millions de dollars
ça fait dix ans que le concours existe
personne ne s'est présenté il ya quatre
milliards de lignes de téléphone
portable au service en france il ya 66
millions ou 44 milliards dans le monde
60 6 millions en france
on a quelques centaines de personnes qui
se disent être sensible le noyau
vraiment grèce ou de france 2000 mhz ce
pas une province d'aydin le noyau
vraiment très très souffrant ces
quelques dizaines de personnes j'en ai
rencontré un certain nombre jeu
certaines manifestement sicot somatise
excessivement j'en ai rencontré une qui
par exemple se sentait très très mal
parce qu'elle avait utilisé un gps de
voiture qui n'émet rien qui capte un
signal venu du ciel
voilà où on en est aujourd'hui à que
choisir n'a pas changé de position
depuis 2008 la dangerosité n'est pas
avéré on est on est d'accord à que
choisir vous défendez les consommateurs
oui et non si ya le danger à ouvrir ici
il ya un danger vous vous devez de le
dire exactement mais le danger n'est
plus là où on l'attendait c'est ça qui a
changé depuis 2008 c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'application du principe de précaution
que nous et que nous approuvons général
nous défendrons même général et de
vêtements délétère parce qu'elle elle
inquiète excessivement un certain nombre
de personnes qui ont des maux de tête
qui ont des migraines qui ont des
douleurs articulaires qui ne trouvent
pas de réponses auprès de la médecine
officielle et leur dire que c'est les
ondes revient à les détourner
jusqu'à mettre leur vie en danger de
cette machine officielle dans le cadre
de mon enquête j'ai rencontré une dame
qui a cinquantaine d'années qui mesure
avec 60 qui fait ps 29 kg et qui
s'apprête à passer l'hiver dans une
caravane sans chauffage électrique parce
qu'une association l'a persuadé que le
courant qui passe dont les fils que nous
avons tous chez nous génère des champs
électriques dangereux pour sa santé
voilà où j'en ai aujourd'hui donc nous
on dit maintenant il faut faire
attention au principe de précaution
parce qu'il peut être dangereux vous
faire avec précaution le principe de
jean cosnard dont je suis extrêmement
choqué par ce que j'entends et je dois
dire que
une association de consommateurs
finalement puisse revenir et sur des
dispositifs concernant la transparence
l'information la concertation on l'a pas
fait à la légère
me choque énormément vraiment donc ça
m'a fait l'alléger j'ai été extrêmement
surprise parce que ce que demande des
consommateurs
c'est bien la transparence l'information
vous n'avez pas les moyens c'est pour
rédiger sur les autres sensibilités en
disant nous avons reçu des dizaines de
milliers de courriers tu es un seul nous
avons 120 0 beaucoup d'élus huit cent
mille électeurs sont concernés par ce
que les gens aient beaucoup de gens
s'inquiètent en laisse par
circonscription ça fait 7 sensible et
mais moi j'ai voulu légiférer dans un
esprit de principe de précaution parce
que on a dans notre histoire
un certain nombre de drames sanitaires
alors je souhaite pas du tout je me suis
peut-être que peut-être que nous n'avons
pas de drames sanitaires en vue en même
temps en quoi est-ce que protéger la
population instaurer un certain nombre
de dispositifs d'information des
personnes de concertation pour
l'implantation des antennes
d'informations concernant ces objets
connectés
en quoi est-ce que ça peut nuire le
potentiel de personnes qui peuvent se
reconnaître dans les symptômes d'être
aussi de sensibilité est énorme ça
correspond à des dizaines de milliers de
patients qui n'ont pas de réponse non à
merveille pendant ma d'accord t'as
classé comme potentiellement
cancérigènes les ondes
électromagnétiques très homogène
bon on est d'accord possibles 0 génocide
cette catégorie correspond à toutes les
substances chercher à conserver noté
sans succès donc à partir d un vaste
fourre tout du tout il yad autres
catégories la catégorie 3 et la
catégorie 4 il ya une aciérie et non
cancérigène pour l'homme et 4 c on peut
pas les cas c'est comme quand ce n est
en rien une substances classées
cancérogènes et elle est toxique par
ailleurs non vous n'avez pas regardé
nous avez pas vous n'avez pas regardé le
tableau messieurs cédric blomme car moi
j'ai répondu à cette question mais je ne
sais pas moi qui vous aimez les environs
désordonnée frais entre vous peut-être
mais ici on est sur un plateau de
télévision donc allez-y
expliquez-moi votre point de vue pour le
coup vous considérez vous que tout cela
est faux
si on a été frappée il ya un article qui
est sorti récemment par la concordance
entre le discours des industriels est
celui qui a adopté que choisir récemment
et on a
que c'est exactement les mêmes arguments
qui sont pris la même façon de sortir
certains éléments du groupe de départ
exemple les produits marine et à la
différence des cornichons sais pas si
vous avez regardé la catégorie des deux
baies meilleurs succès énormément de
choses dit allez au bout de votre
accusation et oui que choisir sur les
talus relier sur l'industrie c'est ça
ils ont exactement les mêmes le travail
d'un blog de manière surprenante ils ont
exactement les nos arguments la même fin
que ceux ci les a félicités donc choisir
sur votre site aujourd'hui la première
chose qu'on trouve c'est comment choisir
son portable choisir sa tablette non
c'est troublant va dire qu'on faisait
remarquer que nous venons de faire
condamner free et que nous sommes
attaqués sans vous attendre depuis de
nombreuses années mais je leur avais
besoin très bien comme ça dit la mère
c'est condamner les trois opérateurs et
sérieusement que choisir pourrait
s'aligner sur la position des opérateurs
par intérêts mercantiles ce que je
comprend pas c'est votre article vous
affirmez les jours il faut c'est qu'on
s'aligne sur les opérateurs faut aller
au bout de votre accusation viens de
vous le dire je vous ai dit je trouve ça
troublant je prends les mêmes tendances
que vous m employer blanc mais c'est à
dire que vous employez exactement les
mêmes arguments vous avez pas tellement
rien dépasse pas les arguments sont vrai
pourquoi est ce que les opérateurs ne
tirait mais parce qu'on les connaît
depuis longtemps et qu'on a vu la façon
dont ils traitent ce problème sanitaire
bon je participe régulièrement à des
réunions avec les opérateurs je vois sur
quels sujets ils ont du mal à répondre
par exemple sur la couverture
d'assurance puisque il ya toujours un
moyen de savoir dans ces histoires
environnementale qui dit la vérité parce
que effectivement les gens débarquent
dans ce sens et là on débarque un peu je
vous vois là y'a un côté même qu'elle
sert cette voie là et donc brutalité au
niveau des moyens de savoir en fait
c'est la position assurantielle dans
l'histoire de l'amiante à partir de 1919
les compagnies d'assurance britanniques
américaines ont cessé de couvrir le
risque sanitaire parce qu'ils estimaient
que c'était trop dangereux
depuis 2000 les principales compagnies
d'assurance mondiales refrain refuse de
couvrir leurs risques sanitaires
associés aux dangers du technique de la
technologie sans fil ça entièrement faux
et même la lloyd's il faut sortir en
octobre 2010 un rapport dans lequel elle
établit un parallèle entre le traitement
du dossier de l'amiante est celui de la
téléphonie mobile
vous répondez les patients inclus les
dommages potentiels des ondes
électromagnétiques dans les contrats de
responsabilité civile que les opérateurs
peuvent souscrire pour leurs antennes
relais c'est un argument qui reviennent
forum en forum mais qu'il faut sauf que
nous avons nous avons droit
certaines compétences en matière
d'assurance à que choisir quand même
écouter on leur a posé la question on a
vu les retours deux jours ci je le redis
la clinique nous avons des documents sur
frappé sa 15 e dans votre discussion et
je vous arrêter là parce que sinon on va
y passer l'émission sur des porcs ont
obtenu congé des téléspectateurs qu'ils
disent ok mais je dois croire croit
alors par exemple qui est un élément
dans le film c'est ce chercheur on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure chercheur
indépendant qui affirme que les
portables ont repris les fréquences
abandonnées par l'armée après que les
radars étaient jugés dangereux
le radar ainsi que les téléphones
portables ont quelque chose en commun
les fréquences qui étaient utilisés à
l'époque par les radars eh bien on était
abandonnés par les militaires ce qu'ils
y trouvaient trop dangereuse pour les
gens qui les manipulent est à dire pour
les radars east il y avait deux sortes
d'effets
le premier effet est l effet thermique
et bien évidemment il y avait les autres
effets qui sont les effets thermiques
que les militaires appelaient à l'époque
effet spécifique c'est-à-dire des
troubles les gens ressentent des
picotements au niveau des mains ont des
sensations de brûlures ont des
sensations
de circulation inversée les membres
deviennent froid et puis après ils ont
des troubles de l'agressivité ils ont
des troubles du sommeil
ils ont des troubles de mémoire et puis
lorsqu'on va voir un peu plus loin
lorsque fait une analyse de sang
s'aperçoit que les hormones répartis
dans le plasma du sang sont répartis de
façon anormale et quand on regarde les
globules blancs qui nous défendent
contre les microbes qu'on appelle les
leucocytes ul et bien il y en a presque
plus donc on ne peut plus haut des
changes ça vous a troublé sa jean-pierre
marque d'abord est ce que c'est vrai que
les fréquences des téléphones portables
on est les anciennes fréquence des
trains je le découvre je vais découvrir
le film je n'ai pas eu le temps parce
que je n'ai vu le film pierre donc je
n'ai mais je vais le vérifier elle est
vérifiée ce qu'on utilise actuellement
dans les radars sont être de 15 ans ont
des fréquences nettement plus élevé
autour de 4 giga hertz e85 gigahertz
alors que même la 4g actuellement ne
montrent pas aussi aussi voulait donc ce
que ce cirque on dispose le plus
d'éléments
c'est sur le lin là de la deuxième
génération qui a été la plus répandue
qui est à 900 mégahertz
donc il est nettement plus basse alors
est-ce qu'il ya eu des radars c'est pas
plus et donc fort y aller le sait c'est
une question de fréquence la fréquence
dans dans l'est
justement pour les radiofréquences en
général ont une pénétration dans le
corps qui dépendent de la longueur
d'onde ou de l' inverse de la fréquence
est donc j'allais dire le le 900
mégahertz pénètrent plus profondément
que le 18 cents ou le 2000 voilà dans le
rapport de 2009 on avait fait un tout
petit chapitre tout aux petits chapitres
sur le sur les radars mais on n'avait
pas connaissance de ce travail de 2 le
russe donc lui je crois qu'il faut qu'on
le lise convoi attentivement convoi avec
les radariste commencer les choses ont
évolué mais il n'est pas impossible qu
effectivement des choses et été décrite
j'entends que vous n'êtes toujours pas
convaincus de la dangerosité du
téléphone portable alors sur l'arrière
saison
là c'est un autre problème j'allais dire
le imac est ce le problème de
l'hypersensibilité électromagnétique est
une chose et puis les problèmes
pathologiques en sont une autre
jusqu'à présent le grand débat et il est
loin d'être résolue porte sur le risque
de tumeur cérébrale
donc il ya tout un ensemble de
pathologies sur lesquels dompter à des
travaux notamment d'une équipe suédoise
et récemment d'une étude française qui
soulève les problèmes d'un risque à o2
chez les gros utilisateurs
au delà de 10 ans et en contribuant à
sens inverse il ya une grande étude
internationale qu'on appelle interphone
qui a eu des résultats mitigés et qui a
été très difficile a publié dieu sait si
on a sollicité les gens pour qu'ils
publient
mais il n'était pas d'accord entre mais
je vois bien oui je le vois sur ce
plateau soit et c'est tout à fait
frappante et on pose on pose une
question et en vérité oui la réponse est
c'est compliqué c'est compris pas là ce
que j'entends c'est compliqué et quand
on entend des scientifiques c'est
compliqué on sait pas répondre
clairement voulu politique vous répondez
on va faire une loi
au cas où cette magie on doit prévoit
quoi pas alors la loi s'appelle sobriété
informations concertation en matière
d'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques donc en fait c'est un
peu un résumé finalement
de l'objectif de la loi sachant que
voilà la loi c'est d'abord la sobriété
dans l'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques
ça fait partie maintenant face à fera
partie ça a été voté déjà deux fois à
l'assemblée au sénat et ça revient donc
à l'assemblée nationale et donc ça fera
partie des objectifs du code des postes
et télécommunications d'appliquer cette
cette sobriété à l'exposition de façon
oui ben c'est une façon de parler de
principe de précaution simplement comme
on peut pas parler de principe de
précaution pour des tas de raisons au
moins a dominé ce que ça veut dire
moderne sobriété seomoz des races à
venir sobriété on fait aussi bas que
possible et c'est l'idée exemple des
émissions le plus bas possible ces
expositions photos a exposé le moins
possible tout en ayant une couverture
c'est-à-dire d'une possibilité
d'utiliser le téléphone portable
voilà donc l'idée c'est d'être exposé le
moins possible tout en ayant donc jeudi
cette couverture de service mais l'autre
point fondamental c'était en lien
beaucoup aussi avec les territoires les
élus locaux c'est de dire comment on
fait pour que l'implantation des relais
de téléphonie mobile se fasse dans
l'information des riverains des
personnes des compris des élus que quand
il ya une modification sur une antenne
de la même façon on souhaite informer et
que si un problème il puisse y avoir une
concertation laquelle concertation peut
aller jusqu'au plus haut niveau
c'est-à-dire l' agence nationale des
fréquences qui verra donc organisera
un conseil de deux suivent et de
dialogue qui peut être une instance de
médiation nationale parce qu'aujourd'hui
quand un opérateur installe une antenne
relais il a besoin d'une autorisation
j'imagine non mais il la plonge lui
demande pas de savoir à quel aujourd'hui
quasiment aucun parmi les moins avancés
j'ai consulté le maire le coup lorsque
le contentieux est en train de
disparaître il ya très très peu de
recours aujourd'hui contre les
installations d'antennes en général les
opérateurs gagnent 99 faut juste
préciser que si on fait des droits parce
que on a coupé le la possibilité aux
citoyens de de solliciter le juge
judiciaire en matière d'implantation
d'antennes-relais donc on s'est
systématiquement chez le juge
administratif qui est naturellement plus
favorable aux opérateurs en général et
aux institutions de la balme en la
justesse initiative serait favorable aux
opérateurs grands dieux mais c'est comme
ça il se trouve qu'on avait que je fasse
dire la justice est vendu macro mais non
pas du tout c'était un peu vite aux
conclusions quand même vous nous
expliquer quand même que le juge
administratif globalement il va trancher
en fa cup
il n'était pas du tout sur le même genre
n'est pas du tout sur la même genre de
problématique il n'est pas sûr le
problème sanitaire le juge administratif
alors que le juge judiciaire lui l'était
et qu'on a pu obtenir le démontage de
certaines antennes relais ce qui a
d'ailleurs provoqué le grenelle des
ondes et ensuite toutes sortes de
politiques publiques qu'elle est dans le
sens de réduire l'exposition du public
grâce grâce au fait qu' il y avait des
juges judiciaires qui avait dit il faut
appliquer le principe de précaution
l'antenne ici pose un problème
il ya un débat scientifique si le débat
venait à se réaliser nous nous trouvons
en face d'un scandale sanitaire
donc il faut démonter cette antenne et
on a utilisé un complot si je vous
écoute pas du tout pas du tout c'est la
justice qui l'a dit on a eu des
jugements qui allaient dans ce sens là
et puis tout d'un coup le tribunal de
cassation s'est s'est dessaisi au profit
du tribunal des conflits qui espèce de
panaché entre la la cour de casser la
cour de cassation d'une part et le
conseil d'état et tout d'un coup on n'a
plus le droit d'aller
d'aller du côté du judiciaire sont des
plats on a le droit de mettre une
antenne sur une école
oui oui on a le droit à ma loi peut le
changer mais ses objectifs en fait c'est
pas forcément de dire on peut pas mettre
une antenne tel ou tel endroit
c'est de placer une antenne là où elle
va je dirais causer le moins de dégâts
si tant est qu effectivement on pense
qu'il ya un danger
allez dans l'exposition aux ondes c'est
vraiment l'idée est là d'arriver aussi
qu'on fera un calcul de ce qu'on appelle
la moyenne nationale sur les émissions
ce calcul sera renouvelée et par des
calculs un peu compliqué je vais pas
détailler ici on pourra on pourra
déterminer
finalement quels sont les seuils maximum
acceptable et donc c'est vraiment cette
ambition là elle est largement partagée
aujourd'hui par parra semble de
parlementaires dans la sidr chez les
citoyens parce que cette inquiétude que
l'on vous dit qu'elle et elle correspond
à rien elle correspond justement je
pense qu'elle correspond effectivement
il n 16 bat jeu je remercie les 16,2 de
son intervention aujourd'hui de classe
étaient sous la couette et bien ils ont
effectivement sur la pointe des pieds
moi j'ai eu de longues discussions avec
l'agent ce donc nationale ce qui ont été
salutaires et qui est vraiment l'organe
en france qui rassemble toutes les
études qui fait le point et qui joue ce
rôle très essentiel et quand on l'a ne
s'est certes dit bon il n'y a pas de
risque avéré mais après quand on lit la
suite du texte la n7 recommande un
certain nombre de précautions d'usagé et
donc c'est quand même aussi un paradoxe
de cet horizon personne ne nous dit
officiellement c'est dangereux et en
même temps dans la fronde des prépas
donc moi mon manager m'a fait une offre
à une copie passagers
un peu schizophrène et ça devient
dangereux mais non c'est pourquoi ce que
ce serait dangereux de protéger la
population dont j'ai simplement partie
serait d'organiser là tout simplement
parce que les partis la motivation va
surinterpréter les messages les gens
sont pas idiots au contraire les
familles ce qu'elle est en train de
faire comment voulez vous que les gens
comprennent exactement terme mardi les i
sur la base des résultats
contradictoires qui existe actuellement
il y a des plusieurs chercheurs des pays
scandinaves et de grande bretagne qui
ont conçu il y a cinq ou six enfin à peu
près une grande étude épidémiologique
qu'on appelle prospective puis ce qu'on
regarde en partir d'une population
sélectionné ce qui va se passer c'est
d'études cosmos qui a débuté
actuellement mais pour pouvoir répondre
clairement
d'ailleurs aussi bien ce qui concerne
les risques de tumeurs cérébrales que
celle des maladies neurovégétatives
dégénératives comme la maladie
d'alzheimer ou la maladie de parkinson
il a été calculé qu'il fallait 200 à 250
milles personnes suivies pendant au
moins 20 ans alors bien sûr qu'on ne
peut pas attendre ces choses là c'était
une est en cours la france est en train
de s'y joindre actuellement financement
de l'ansès je voudrais préciser pour
qu'on comprenne bien là que vous ne
venez pas de lier les ondes
électromagnétiques ni à parkinson ni à
alzheimer simplement qu'il faut 20 ans
pour mener une enquête sérieuse sur ce
sujet là les ondes avait en effet
bénéfique possible dans l'appréhension
d'azheimer ce que les chercheurs près
avec énormément de précautions
pourtant il est bien possible mais pour
le moment il faut bien comprendre la
situation des scientifiques je pense que
mon voisin ne démentira pas on est dans
la certitude les cantons et en lundi
dans l'incertitude
on ne sait pas les effets pour refaire
des effets positifs écoutez dernier
élément qui joue verse au dossier puis
je vais vous donner la parole tout ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est la parole très
forte dans le documentaire tout à
l'heure de cet homme qui depuis son
refuge des vosges la zone blanc les
vosges qui là qu'il a trouvé où il n'y
aurait pas d' onde nous lance cet
avertissement
l'errance elle est imposée aujourd'hui à
des personnes qui sont absolument pas
préparés à le vivre
un monsieur tout le monde qui est
ouvrier ingénieurs pharmaciens un peu
tout le monde et du jour au lendemain
vous retrouver sur la route avec
avec plus rien pas un seul petit endroit
où vous pouvez vous poser et vous êtes
en en perpétuelle quête d'un endroit où
vous êtes bien et vous vous le trouvez
pas et c'est terence que nous tout cela
on dit depuis quelques mois quelques
années
c'est ce qui pour nous pend au nez à peu
près de tout le monde c'est à dire que
vous êtes tous des achats sans devenir
dans la mesure où pour nous on cherche
des endroits où vivre et y en a plus et
s'il y en a plus pour nous il y en aura
bientôt plus pour vous et il faudra que
tout le monde se bat pour avoir un
environnement propre autour de lui on
peut pas à quelques dizaines de
personnes le hs faire basculer les
politiques vers le raisonnable
est ce que vous imaginez sérieusement
etienne cendrier que les électro
hypersensibles et on met pas en doute
leurs souffrances dans cette affaire est
ce que vous imaginez qu'on souhaite tous
que me demain c'est impossible à dire ça
c'est impossible à dire en revanche
qu'il ya de plus en plus l'agent
franchement c'est très inquiétant quand
on entend ça parce que sur eux ils le
vivent
il se trouve que voilà deux du fait de
mon rôle associatif
je vis compter au quotidien avec des
électrodes pas ressentir au début j'ai
eu la même histoire un peu comme marc
khanne je faisais des débats j'étais sur
la dangereuse khalil el général en terre
des ondes électromagnétiques
artificielle est régulièrement je me
faisais alpaguer on peut dire à la
sortie des débats pas d électro
hypersensibles jamais tu fais rien pour
nous et yan tu fais rien pour nous et il
m'a fallu un certain temps que certains
électrohypersensibles viennent
travailler au sein de l'association pour
que je comprenne la première année vous
allez maintenant est-ce qu'ils sont les
précurseurs alors d'un mal qui va nous
frapper tous ce que c'est une catégorie
de gens qui on ne fait pas ce qui nous
inquiète c'est qu'il ya des enfants qui
deviennent électrohypersensibles et que
par ailleurs il ya une exposition
maintenant pour les enfants qui sont
conçus maintenant prénatal ce que ça va
donner plus tard c'est à dire que les
enfants comme pour moi j'ai été conçu il
n'y avait pas ces ondes
électromagnétiques artificielle n'y
avait pas ces technologies pour les
enfants qui sont conçus maintenant ils
sont conçus dans cet environnement
l'effet que ça aura plus tard le
l'impact que savoir à haut niveau d
électro hypersensibles ça on ne le
connaît pas ce que nous cherchons à
obtenir
c'est une réglementation qui permettent
d'avoir une exposition minimale pour
éviter au cas où
pas simplement au cas où pourra éviter
des pathologies parce que pour nous le
débat scientifique en fait on est sur
une position où pour nous les choses
sont claires c'est on sait déjà que
c'est dangereux de toutes sortes de
manières il ya encore des mécanismes sur
lesquels il faut travailler vous des
conseils des deux pigeons ne sait pas
donc rallié rapport aux anciens je suis
tombé récemment selon un rapport de la
nasa qui date de 1992
19 qui parlait déjà
d'électro-hypersensibilité donc la nasa
c'est par des petits
je parle de la dangerosité de l'électro
hypersensibilité erwan seznec vous vous
vous reconnaissez qu'il peut y avoir des
seuils raisonnable en matière de
l'émission une petite parenthèse ce
qu'il faut quand même qu'on rigole un
peu dans ce débat il ya une association
s'appelle le criirem elle un conseil
scientifique dans son conseil
scientifique à quelqu'un qui a
d'ailleurs représenté le criirem devant
lanxess et qui croient que les
anticyclones sont contrôlés par les
radars météo des américains qui ont
provoqué des pluies diluviennes dans les
pays qui s'opposaient à leur politique
en irak
il croit également le virus de hiv de
l'ebola ont été créées par les services
secrets occidentaux pour contrôler la
natalité en afrique
il faut vraiment vraiment faire un
effort pour pas avoir envie de rire donc
vous en gros vous les traitez de dengue
peut lui en l'occurrence je juge écrit
qui s'enregistrent n'était pas celui
d'un scientifique ordinaire il est
pourtant conseil scientifique du criirem
des gens sérieux par mieux pour vous je
l'espère je l'espère je le souhaite je
le crois en face de vous vous avez des
gens sérieux ou pas d'accord autour de
vous d'ailleurs parce que même le
neurologue je crois que il ya des gens
très sérieux qui s'occupe de lettres
sensibilité je crois qu'il ya des gens
qui souffrent énormément et de la
souffrance parfois peut faire perdre la
lucidité je vous repose la question est
ce qu'il ya des seuils raisonnable pour
vous d'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques des réseaux n'a par
exemple de limiter ça comme très
présomptueux pour nous de d'éditer des
seuils mais ceux qui sont en vigueur
actuellement nous semble tout à fait
satisfaisant donc le problème des seuils
la fin d'un problème un petit peu
compliqué il faut simplifier alors
simplifier les i dans le cadre si vous
voulez les seuils de lynn spears irp qui
on est et qu'il instances
internationales qui définit ces seuils a
surtout eu pour but de d'éviter les
effets thermiques des radiofréquences
au delà d'une certaine énergie les
radiofréquences provoque de la chaleur
et la chaleur et est mauvaise pour le
corps dont 20 très bien voilà mais le
problème qui est en discussion
actuellement on est au dessous de ce
seuil
on est au dessous de ce seuil de ligne
ici et donc si
se dire il y as peut-être il ya
peut-être des effets non thermiques et
cela c'est très difficile à caractériser
il faut trouver actuellement on a on a
des projets de recherche là dessus il
faut trouver des paramètres qu'ils
soient qui est comment dirais-je une
relation possible avec à la fois la
biologie et la pathologie donc et pour
la recherche de c'est ce que j'ai
compris les histoires de ça et c'est
quand même il ya quand même quelque
chose d'un peu amusant tout de même
équilibre de simples de la simple
logique là c'est pas besoin d'être calé
en sciences pour comprendre
on ad ce qui commence ne pas faire trop
de technique à 41 volts par mètre qui
nous protège t en clair contre la
cuisson ce qu'on appelait les effets
thermiques ont il ya un effet thermique
du au micro-ondes on est protégé contre
la cuisson pour autant l'agencé
nationale des fréquences qui est un peu
le gendarme de l'utilisation de ces
fréquences considère que à 6 volts par
mètre donc largement en dessous on est
dans une exposition atypique
donc moi je pose une question de bon
sens si 41 volts par mètre et plus plus
l'infini nous protège et sont vraiment
protecteur de la santé pourquoi est-ce
que s'ils veulent permettre on serait
dans une exposition atypique
est ce que vous connaissez un seul
domaine de la législation française ou
bien de façon atypique de respecter la
légalité
oui on voit bien qu'ils aient un souci
c'est à dire que la plupart des
enregistrements actuellement tourne
autour de 1 volt par mètre et 2 2 par
endroits il y a des même plus puisque
six semaines a dit joe alors qu'on
s'interroge sur sur ces choses là qu'est
ce qui les fait donc il ya des équipes
notamment suisses qui ont modélisé toute
la ville de bâle pour voir comment se
créent ces points du fait des réflexions
des zones enfin c'est un sujet j'allais
dire qui et qui est difficile mais ce
que pour ce qui est de lancer cela je
peux parler parce que c'est sur la base
des deux rapports qui ont été déjà guéri
2009 et 2013
nous sommes pour le principe alara que
défend madame abeilles c'est à dire
aussi bas que possible au sibac peut
être aussi bas que possible pour
terminer en une minute
bon allez je veux garder mon portable
s'il vous plaît mais je vous en prie
c'est possible je voudrais garder mon
wifi à la maison je regardais mon
téléphone sur la base son fils est ce
que j'ai donné des consignes à respecter
de précaution bien sûr continuer à vivre
comme je vis avec ma technologie wii
avec la précaution nécessaires aux ide
en mémoire les précautions fait par
exemple avec le téléphone portable s'est
portée des maîtres des oreillettes
voilà c'est tout simple jamais mais
jamais à la tête ça c'est la deuxième
chose sur le téléphone à base si on peut
s'en passer c'est aussi bien téléphone
sans fil des ect
voilà sinon il faut éviter de dormir à
côté pareil pour les maisons le à basse
consommation et éviter de les mettre à
côté d'une table de nuit
le wifi il faut pouvoir le désactiver ou
l'activé simplement est donc cette on
peut le faire chez soi et puis qu'on y
compris parler avec ses voisins
éventuellement pour quand on est dans un
milieu urbain on reçoit lé wifi de 20
personnes autour éventuellement de
parler à voile à ses voisins pour dire
on en reste donc il ya des choses qu'on
peut faire de plus c'est simple mais la
loi est nécessaire j'insiste là dessus
parce que même s'il ya des chartes dans
un certain nombre de villes et qui sont
des chartes intéressante qui fonctionne
bien il faut une égalité du territoire
il faut que la loi puisse permettre que
cette prod cette protection
que peut apporter cette première pierre
un j'ai bien dans la protection des
populations à l'exposition aux champs
électromagnétiques soit partagée pour
l'ensemble de la population française
bon courage pour la pluie surtout à
protéger vos enfants c'est les enfants
et la protégeant tous premiers lots ne
pas leur offrir de portable j'ai failli
passer dans la loi que les moins de 6
ans n'est pas de portable et pas de
tablette pas de petits objets connectés
pour les enfants plusieurs est là avant
tout bon courage pour faire appliquer ça
à la maison bien évidemment merci à tous
les cadres n'est pas convaincu ou moins
erwens s d'accès très clair son enquête
et un lien dans que choisir si vous le
souhaitez j'ajoute de livres celui de
marine richard vous avez vu dans le
documentaire s'appelle sous l'ondé elle
est électro hypersensibles et celui de
jean yves cendrey qui s'appelle jeu
mme roman avorté et récits de mon mal
c'est publié chez actes sud ça c'est
pour compléter votre documentation
merci encore une fois la semaine
prochaine avec la barre ça qu'on
évoquera l'empiré nestlé
on sera de retour en afrique avec le
rôle des multinationales là bas je vous
dis à très vite sur public sénat